in one game a code made using different
colors is created by one player the code
maker and the other player the code
breaker tries to guess the code the code
maker gives hints about whether the
colors are correct and in the right
position all right
the possible colors are blue let me
underline these in the actual colors
blue
yellow
blue yellow white
white
red
orange
and green green's already written in
green with all underlined in green again
and green
how many four color codes can be made if
the colors cannot be repeated to some
degree this whole paragraph in the
beginning doesn't even
matter if we're just choosing from let's
see we're choosing from how many colors
are there there's one two
three four five six colors and we're
gonna pick four of them how many four
color codes can be made if the colors
cannot be repeated
and since these are codes i'm we're
going to assume that
blue
that blue
red
red yellow
yellow and
green
that this
that that is different than green
red
green red
yellow
yellow and blue we're going to assume
that these are not the same code even
though we've picked the same four colors
we're going to assume that these are two
different codes and that makes sense
because we're dealing with codes so
these are
different
codes different codes so this would
count as two different codes right here
even though we've picked even though
we've picked the same actual colors the
same four colors we picked them in
different orders now with that out of
the way let's think about how many
different ways we can pick four colors
so let's say we have four slots here we
have four slots one slot two slot three
slot and four slots and at first we care
only about
how many ways can we pick a color for
that slot right there that first slot we
haven't picked any colors yet well we
have six possible colors one two three
four five six so there's going to be six
different possibilities for this slot
right there so let's put a six right
there
now they told us that the colors cannot
be repeated so whatever color is in this
slot we're going to take it out of the
possible colors so now that we've taken
that color out how many possibilities
are when we go to this slot when we go
to the next slot how many possibilities
when we go to the next slot right here
well we took one of the six out for the
first slot so there's only five
possibilities here and by the same logic
when we go to the third slot we've used
up two of the slots two of the colors
already so there's only before possible
colors left and then for the last slot
we would have used up three of the
colors so there's only three
possibilities left so if we think about
all of the possibilities all of the
permutations and permutations or we
think about all the possibilities and
you do care about order where you say
that this is different than this this is
a different permutation than this so all
of the different permutations here
when you when you pick four colors out
of a possible of six colors
it's going to be six
six possibilities for the first one
times five for the second bucket times
four for the fourth for the third or the
or the third bucket of the third
position times three so six times five
is
thirty times four is times three so
thirty times twelve so this is thirty
times twelve which is equal to their
three hundred and sixty possible
four color codes